this is Miss City on City on Hello nice
to meet you guys hi hi hello to Marvel
we were just talking about the fact that
this is your very first film Premiere
what's it like to be here oh my gosh
it's amazing I never thought that
playing video games was gonna get me on
the purple carpet here interviewing with
you guys and hanging out with Marvel but
what a journey it's been I'm glad to be
here
so let me ask you this because even
though it's your first carpet you did
not come to play tell us about this
outfit because you look amazing head to
toe I love everything thank you well I'm
dressed today I got everything from
stockx so I have my Chanel earrings and
my off-white dress I have my Amina moati
shoes and then I have my Brandon
Blackwood and systemic racism bag here
this is purple little number I love it
and we get like a little highlight on
that bag really quickly okay the color
match so it's beautiful I love the way
it matches my dress I am like super
super happy with the way I'm dressed
tonight well we know you're a great
stockx Ambassador obviously head to toe
can you tell us a little bit about your
love of Marvel the Marvel fandom how
that's always integrated for you into
video games as well yeah absolutely so
um I was just explaining earlier like I
grew up with bedtime stories but it was
comic books so my dad is like the
biggest Marvel fan and that was what I
was learning about when I was a kid and
what I was reading so it just
transcended into this like thing I
started gaming reading comics more
talking about comics on stream and now
I'm at a Marvel Premiere it happens like
that yeah wow and you know what does it
mean for you to be at this Marvel
Premiere in particular what does that
mean to you oh gosh it means everything
like I think that you know feeling like
I'm a piece of representation and gaming
for like younger black women younger
just black kids in general to be able to
be here and see representation on the
big screen and be able to celebrate that
is the absolute best feeling for my
first Premiere I wouldn't have wanted it
any other way absolutely That's so
exciting well as our final question we
have to ask is there anyone you're
insanely excited to see tonight anything
you're insanely excited to see tonight
uh I have to go with just the movie in
general like I'm so so excited like I
every time I've watched the trailer for
Black Panther I've gotten chills like
just absolute tears I know it's gonna be
a moving one and I'm very excited
absolutely get in there then we'll see
you inside great to meet you